Don't you sometimes wonder why so many
immigrants who come to America can build
a new life and a fortune,
while many of the people who were born
here are barely surviving,
they have a dream,
a defined goal,
ambition aside from the pioneers that
crossed the prairies and the mountains
to reach their vision of hope and future
promises.
There are other amazing examples of how
ambition has shaped America.
Take Ben Franklin for instance,
when most people think of Ben Franklin,
they remember the kite and the lightning
bolt and the discovery of electricity.
What a lot of people may not know is
that Ben Franklin was one of the first
riders to address self making when
Franklin started poor Richard's Almanac
in 1732.
He used the blank spaces between the
crop data and the weather information to
insert clever bits of moral and
practical advice.
I'm sure you've heard the saying fish
and companies start to stink in three
days.
Well,
that was one of hundreds of Ben
Franklin's comments on life.
Another was diligence is the mother of
good luck.
You know,
it's amazing how hard working smart
working people have.
All the luck we sometimes hear of a
brand new musical group and overnight
success,
they must have been in the right place
at the right time,
knew the right people and a friend to
help them out.
But if you've ever watched an interview
with some of these folks,
you'll probably hear that there
overnight success took several years.
Diligence is the mother of good luck.
Now,
in addition to these witticisms,
Ben Franklin gave us three principles of
success and ambition that have withstood
the test of time.
Number one,
happiness doesn't come from big pieces
of great success,
but from small advantages hammered out
day by day.
What Mr Franklin is saying here is that
we must be happy with what we've got.
When we're in pursuit of what we want
to.
Often we say,
oh,
I'll be happy when I just get that
promotion.
I'll be happy when I just land that
contract.
I'll be happy when I just have more
money.
I'll be happy when I just.
Just what?
You won't be any happier when you reach
your goals than you are right now.
It just doesn't work that way.
Abraham Lincoln said it best,
he said,
you'll be as happy as you make up your
mind to be right now.
Whether you're on your way,
whether you've already gotten there,
you'll be as happy as you make your mind
to be.
Now,
right now,
being happy on the way doesn't mean you
can't aim for great things.
After all,
look at everything Franklin accomplished
in his lifetime.
It means that big achievements come one
small advantage at the time.
It means that you've got to enjoy the
journey.
It means that you must enjoy and take
pride in your little accomplishments.
It means enjoying who you are becoming
in pursuit of your eager desire.
Every day,
every single day,
Ben Franklin,
second principal,
said that life is plastic within each of
us is the power to mold,
mold ourselves and mold our environment.
It is up to each of us to begin this
molding process with a final product in
mind,
and it is within our power to work it.
Inform it every minute,
every day,
every month,
every year.
By using your mind and your abilities
and your attitude to work a little each
day on molding your life,
you'll soon see how magnificent your
power is to gain those small advantages
each day,
the little steps it takes to build up to
success.
Principle number three,
successes.
The pleasure.
Success is a pleasure.
If what you are doing today isn't
satisfying,
gratifying,
guess what?
You're really not successful.
If you are not fulfilled with what you
are doing today,
you cannot possibly be successful.
It doesn't matter how many worldly
possessions you may have,
how many cars,
how many toys,
how much money?
If you're not happy with your life as it
is,
you cannot be successful.
Now,
I know that success is a relative term.
It means different things to different
people.
To a school kid,
success may mean a star on top of his
latest test to a homemaker.
It probably means that she has a well
run household and a wonderful family to
an outside professional.
It's most likely the thrill of closing a
major contract or the pride and
accepting a performance bonus or being
named the top producing sales person,
but the one thing you will hear from
everyone who is successful is that they
are happy with who they are and what
they are doing.
They are happy content,
satisfied successes of pleasure.
What have you done today that makes this
day successful?
Think about it and write it down.
If at the end of the day,
you can jot down the things that have
made it a good day,
you will soon see patterns.
For me.
This really is a good habit to get into.
When you can see a of pleasure,
you'll know you're on the road to
success
though.
Take note of Mr. Franklin's three
principles of success and ambition.
Number one,
big achievements come one small
advantage at a time,
one step at a time,
one day at a time.
Number two,
you have the power to mold your life,
to make it whatever you want to shape it
and reshape it,
and number three,
success is measured through pleasure.
This is the key one.
Success is measured through pleasure.
You've got to be happy along the way.
You've got to learn to give yourself a
pat on the back.
Good job.
You need to tell yourself,
I'm proud of me today.
You've got to be happy.
You've got to learn to enjoy the
process.
These are really common sense ideas.
They're practical and William James
agreed.
He's another American great.
One of the most notable philosophers and
psychologists in our history and he
founded a philosophy called pragmatism.
To be pragmatic is to be practical,
to test the validity of a concept by its
practical results,
to actually question something and rate
it's usefulness by what it can do for
you to hear a method of,
yeah,
doing something and figuring out if it's
even worth your while.
One of the issues Mr James dealt with in
his lifetime was what does it mean to be
a success?
A significant person after years of
palm.
During this question,
William James described yes as a
combination of two things.
Number one and inner ideal,
which is followed persistently with
courage and number two,
outer achievement related to that ideal.
Let's go back to number one and enter
ideal,
which is followed persistently with
curry.
I take that to mean defining a goal and
having the resolve to complete it.
No matter what,
I'll do it or die.
Promise yourself.
You'll read the books until your skills
change.
Go to the seminars until you get a
handle on it.
Do it until it makes sense.
Practice it until you've got it right.
Don't give up until you get where you
want to be.
However long that is,
step by step,
piece by piece,
book by book,
seminar by seminar.
Do it until,
go for it until as a very important
word.
It's magic.
It means that you'll never give up.
Don't miss the chance to grow,
to pay the price.
Until you learn,
change,
grow.
You'll discover some of life's great
treasures when you pay that price.
William James Second part to success
dealt with the outer achievement related
to that ideal.
You need both aspects to really be a
success,
but what Dr James Realized about his
philosophy of success was that the first
part is indeed more important.
Then the second going for it.
As long as you're working toward your
inner goal,
your dream,
then success is possible,
but once you give up your innovation,
then you can never become successful.
You never will become successful until
it doesn't even matter.
Now,
maybe the person who's been working on a
project for 10 years can be successful
in his own right if he's honestly
working toward it,
doing everything to make himself worthy
of reaching the dream,
really happy with where he is.
According to the Christian story.
The first couple,
Adam and eve were instructed to be
fruitful,
produce some results,
fruitful.
It's kind of an interesting word.
It's sort of denotes abundance.
Here's what I think,
fruitful and abundance and productivity,
and I think here's what it means to go
to work on producing more than you need
for yourself.
Go to work,
producing more than you need for
yourself,
and I think we fulfill that command so
long ago given to be fruitful,
to be productive,
to produce far more than you need for
yourself so that you can bless others
and bless your community.
Bless your nation.
Bless you.
Were enterprise
producing more ideas than you need for
yourself that you could share and give
them all away,
produce more in terms of substance and
money and treasure and all things
valuable to human beings,
far more than you need for yourself.
Rg laterno story.
The man who built the big earth moving
machines,
it was his goal to someday give away 90
percent of income
giving away far more than anyone could
possibly imagine.
Someone says,
wow,
90 percent is enough to give away.
Well,
you should have seen the 10 percent that
was left.
I mean,
once abundance starts to come.
Once someone becomes incredibly
productive,
it's amazing what the numbers turn out
to be.
It's amazing what it finally totals
incredible,
so hopefully we'll have guidelines for
you during this weekend so you can turn
the response you've created already by
being here.
Then the response by employing your
mental activity and taking notes,
putting all this through your mental
processes so that you can create this
kind of results when you leave here.
Next
best way to make the most out of this
weekend is just a few things.
Number one,
be thankful for what you already have.
This looks like a pretty prosperous
audience already,
so we're already doing well,
which is okay,
but what if we could multiply the value
of our productivity by two,
by three,
by five,
by 10?
Would that be valuable?
The answer is yes,
of course it would,
but first of all,
to have the mechanism or the inspiration
or whatever it takes to really do
extremely well.
First,
you start with Thanksgiving to be
thankful for what you all ready,
Eh,
we have already solved the problem of
necessity in this room.
We've probably already solved the
problem of survival,
so we're no longer concerned with just
necessity and survival.
We are perhaps beyond that,
but now that we have gotten beyond that,
no telling what else we can do,
but first of all,
let's be thankful for what we've
accomplished up until now,
the years that have brought me here and
the experiences that brought me here.
Starting with my parents who raised me,
gave me an incredible foundation that's
lasted me all of these years and the
mentors that I've met along the way.
Absolutely the changing and
revolutionizing my life,
my income,
my bank account,
my future,
all of that collectively has brought me
here.
I'm so grateful for the people,
the Association for the ideas,
for the chance to work in labor,
produced myself,
all of that that brought me to this
place,
uh,
this weekend.
I'm grateful for it.
For the countries we represent,
where we have freedom.
Liberty,
make this note.
It's one of the best for the day.
These are extraordinary times.
About 11 years ago,
the walls came tumbling down in Germany
and it started a wave of democracy and
freedom like the world has ever seen
before.
It looked like communism was on the
march for so many years in the dark
shadow of that political philosophy fell
on so many countries that I visited it
even back in those early,
early days.
And now those shadows are beginning to
flee away in the light of democracy and
freedom and capitalism is,
is now the order of the day and there's
just a few old dictators left and they
will soon be gone.
Here's the good news.
In our lifetime,
they will all be gone.
That's an incredible thought to think
the dictators of the past will all be
gone.
Years and years ago when I went to South
America,
almost every country had a dictator.
Now they're all gone.
I mean in that whole hemisphere,
there's only one left and that's Castro
and he will soon be gone and the
Qaddafi's will soon be gone and this at
am.
Hussein's will soon be gone and they
will all be gone because now,
once this wave of capitalism and freedom
and free enterprise and spirituality now
sweeping the whole world,
once it started all those years ago,
I'm telling you,
it is such an incredible sight to see.
I now have the opportunity to lecture in
East Germany into lecture in
Czechoslovakia and Poland.
Now,
last time I was in Poland,
we had a bomb scare,
was incredible middle of the winter.
And uh,
they said,
you know,
there's a bomb in the place.
So we all vacated and went out in the
winter.
I stayed for about,
I don't know,
20,
25 minutes while they brought in the
sniffing dogs to clear the place and no
one left.
Everyone came back in middle of the
winter in Poland,
so that means everything is changing.
Jim Rowan,
teaching capitalism in Moscow and in
Siberia Novosibirsk.
I'm one of the few that's been sent to
Siberia that came back
and now I'm going again,
hoping I get back again.
Incredible.
These are extraordinary times,
politically,
socially,
and every other way.
There's never been anything like it in
the history of the last 6,000 years of
the human race.
It's extraordinary.
These are extraordinary times
politically with freedom on the march,
socially,
economically extraordinary times.
So make this note,
Jim Rollins view of the 21st century
unprecedented opportunity.
Every field you can imagine,
every endeavor you want to try,
unprecedented opportunity
of course,
along with all the challenges that we
faced forever.
This is a new day.
This is a new way.
This is a new scene nationally and for
each of us personally,
nothing like it.
Unprecedented opportunity.
Now,
here's number two,
the 21st century keen competition.
It's called world competition.
Now,
not just person to person,
not company to company,
not the industry to industry.
What happens on the other side of the
world.
Now it greatly affects us on this side
of the world,
so it's a world game to play.
This is one of our chances now to play
the world game.
I travel all over the world.
I mean,
it's incredible.
I leave Los Angeles 14 hours later.
I'm in Tokyo.
Five meals,
three movies in.
You're there.
I mean,
this is easy stuff.
I fly the concord,
right?
Three hours.
London,
New York.
These are extraordinary times.
In about 10 days I'll be down in South
America,
Argentina,
Venezuela,
incredible.
The jets fly everywhere and then all
night long,
the jets fly to our countries,
bringing us goods and services and
fruits and vegetables from anywhere in
the world.
It's unbelievable.
These are extraordinary times.
Unprecedented Opportunity,
but keen competition.
So here's what you need now to really be
successful in the 21st century.
Number one is multiple skills.
Hopefully we'll talk about some of those
skills this weekend.
Don't be caught now in the 21st century
with just one skill.
If you want to flourish,
be fruitful.
If you want to grow,
produce more than you need for yourself.
Learn more than one skill.
This is also my perception now and
traveling around the world.
It would be useful to know more than one
language,
learn more than one language.
My father spoke German when I was a kid
growing up,
but he never taught me.
My mother was English,
but she also spoke French,
but she never taught me.
I could have learned three languages at
the same time.
These extra languages are so useful.
I ask a teacher one time,
how many languages going to child learn?
Here's what you said.
As many as you'll teach them,
they don't lack capacity.
They don't lack imagination.
They certainly don't let curiosity.
They only lack of teacher,
so if you think learning another
language is sort of passed you by.
Make this note,
give it as a gift to your tools.
Another language,
and then another language.
When I lecture in the Scandinavian
countries,
they all speak several languages.
I do my seminars in English because they
can all understand English.
In the Scandinavian countries,
you're required to learn four languages
during your educational process.
Three,
they assigned in one.
You can choose,
so when you finished the educational
process in the Scandinavian countries,
you now know for languages which if you
live in Europe is a great advantage,
but it's a great advantage anywhere
learning that extra language.
Some of my business colleagues that make
mega millions every year,
many of them speak more than one
language,
several languages.
Michael Coles speaks seven languages.
It's so much fun to travel around the
world with Michael because he can talk
to anybody.
Everybody.
He knows all the languages.
It's a gift,
a gift to give to your tooth.
Okay,
so anyway,
I said all that to say this.
Oh,
one more.
Learn all the disciplines that make
language and skills worthwhile,
the disciplines of good health
disciplines of staying vital.
We'll talk about that just a little bit
later.
So that's your best advantage for the
21st century.
So of all,
be thankful.
Here's the next one.
Now to make this weekend.
Really powerful for you to be eager to
learn and I hesitate to say that because
you know you wouldn't be here if you
weren't eager to learn to pay the price
of time and money and it wasn't the
money that was really the expensive part
for this weekend.
It was the time
you haven't made that note before.
Make it now.
Time is more valuable than money.
You can get more money,
but you can't get more time.
So to ask you for the price for the
seminar,
fairly modest,
but to ask you for the price in time for
the seminar,
incredibly expensive to ask me for three
days.
I mean that's.
It's a heavyweight cost for me,
but it's exactly the same for you.
Three days is a chunk of time and so the
biggest investment for this weekend is
not the money.
The biggest investment is the time.
So here's what I want to happen.
I want this investment to pay off for
you multiplied many times over what will
the seminar be worth?
Not The price it cost to get in and not
the really the price of time.
It may be worth a thousand times more
than that.
What if I tried to make the seminar
worth just exactly what you paid.
That would be difficult.
What if I tried to make it worth a
thousand times more than you think?
I'm telling you?
That might be easier because I'm
inspired by ideas that have worked
miracles in my life and I want to share
them with you,
so I want you to be a lot Richard,
when you walk out.
Then when you walked in,
so be eager to learn.
Take good notes.
You know,
no matter how well you do,
no matter,
no telling what else you can do.
You know if you're mega rich,
you might become super mega rich.
Right after this weekend
we had the millionaire's club often
invite a billionaire to come talk to us.
He says,
well,
you guys are doing okay,
but you know,
come on,
get your act together.
So no matter how rich you are,
here's what's possible.
If you can multiply it by two by three,
by five,
by 10,
with the right idea,
the right inspiration,
the right collective association here,
this weekend,
it's going to give you a good chance.
Now,
here's the next one.
Argue later with all my stuff.
I wish we had time to open it up so we
could debate all this stuff right on the
spot.
Debate later with all of my ideas and
the things I'm going to share with you,
but make this note now debate is
important.
That's why we have at least two parties
in Congress to debate good ideas.
Communism said no one party sufficient,
but see lacking debate.
It's easy to become tyrannical.
Power tends to corrupt.
Absolutely.
So without debate,
you know something can gather far too
much power.
So it's important and a lot of the
issues I'm going to raise this weekend,
a lot of the stuff I'm going to share
with you is up for debate.
Here's why it's up for debate.
I can only share with you my point of
view
and there's got to be more than one
point of view.
If I looked at something from over here
and I said,
here's what it looks like to me,
and you were standing over there and
looking back this way at it,
you would say,
no,
it.
Here's what it looks like to me now.
If I invited you from back over there to
come up here and look at it from where I
am,
you might say,
Gosh,
you're right Mr Allen.
I never looked at it before from this
vantage point,
so that's what I want to do in the
speakers we've got this weekend are
going to gather all of this up and share
ideas from our point of view,
but here's what you must remember.
There's more than one point of view,
so here's what's important to be a
student,
not a follower,
to be a student,
and part of being a student is to
debate.
The idea is once you hear them,
you say,
right or wrong,
could it work for me?
Not Work for me.
Is it a,
is that a little too heavy or isn't it
sufficient enough?
Now,
sometimes it's useful to debate with
each other.
I'm a good debater,
right?
If I choose one side,
I don't really care which side to
choose,
you know,
just pick a side,
go for it.
I remember a great debate.
I really heard someone in America was
debating someone in Canada that held a
little more liberal position and the
American was very conservative and the
American said,
every man for himself,
individual individualism,
rugged individualism,
and on the other side the liberal said,
well,
yes,
every man for himself said the elephant
is he danced among the chickens.
I thought,
hey,
that's a pretty good point.
So whether it's liberal or Conservative,
we need both.
In America,
the Declaration of Independence is
America's great liberal doctrine and the
constitution of the United States is
America's great conservative document.
So it takes a bit of both,
but to debate the idea.
Now,
if you can't debate with someone,
here's what you must learn to do.
Debate with yourself.
Is it valuable or isn't it valuable?
Is this idea I've heard a bit off track
or is it on track?
Would it be useful or not?
Be useful
to debate the merits of trying to beat
the merits of putting it into action.
So debate is a way to refine a good
idea.
Someone in Congress says,
I have an idea for the country,
and the rest of them say wonderful.
Put it on the table.
So someone asks three questions and this
guy says,
wow,
I never thought of those questions.
I withdraw my great idea.
Well,
it's a good thing we didn't try it on
the country.
So here's why we learned from multiple
voices,
but we don't become followers.
We become students.
And that is to refine ideas that can
change our health,
change our income,
change your future,
change everything for the better.
Make us more productive to finally have
far more in productivity than we need
for ourselves,
but eager to learn.
Exercise,
good debate.
Now here's the last part to make this a
valuable weekend.
And that's to be a good listener.
And then no,
that's not going to be easy.
You know,
most of our life is going on outside
these four walls.
You know our businesses out there and
our customers are out there and you
know,
the store we run is out there and our
children are out.
There are families out there and our
friends are out there,
everything.
Most of the things that involve our life
are out there.
So sometimes when a big part of our life
that's going on out there,
it's a little hard to sort of dismiss
all of that for awhile.
Put it into a place where you can just
push it aside for just a little while
and really listened intently and gather
up the information,
but I know you're going to do your best.